johnny depp versus amber heard trial in
less than 24 hours we're going to hear
the critical closing arguments in this
case and today in court an emotional
amber broke down on the stand
this is horrible this is painful
this is humiliating for any human being
to go through
even just walking into this courtroom
i receive
hundreds
of death threats
regularly
people want to put my baby in the
microwave they tell me that every single
day i have to relive the trauma
many people who have watched this trial
have found some of amber hurt's
testimony to be a bit over the top oh no
one ever has to go through something
like this
the jury has to decide is this someone
that's being
forthright with us or is this someone
that is just performing for us
johnny is
one of the most gifted actors we have
amber's world has changed dramatically
since we sat down with her back in 2011.
she had just recently met johnny he's
also a wonderful person
wonderful human being after amber's
emotional testimony today a tough
cross-examination by johnny's attorney
trial breakout star camille vasquez
legal analyst julie rendellman says
she's been effective but we always go
back to that one question what does the
jury think does the jury think abrahad's
being picked on it's heard there is no
question pending and i would appreciate
it if you wouldn't be making argument to
the jury sorry that you had asked me
about it
no i didn't ask you about anything
one issue this leaked video shot by
amber which shows johnny angry in his
kitchen the video came from you right
miss heard
no it did not
but did amber tip off the paparazzi why
would i want that what actual survivor
of domestic violence wants that
yesterday this former tmz employee who
testified about being alerted that amber
would be filing a temporary restraining
order sparred with the actress's
attorney you know this case is being
televised right i am aware that there
are cameras and so this gets you your 15
minutes of fame i'm not seeking any 15
minutes here though you may you're
welcome to speculate i could say the
same thing by taking amber hurt as a
client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly i find that to be purely
logical